AASTHA BHARDWAJ: Welcome.
My name is Aastha, and I'm an
engineer on the Cloud SQL team.
In this video, I'll show you
how to create, run, and manage
SQL instances using
Google Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL helps manage
mundane administrative tasks
for MySQL and Postgres
databases so you
can focus on what matters.
Let's walk through how to create
a MySQL database on Cloud SQL
and connect to it from
the Google Cloud shell.
You can set up an instance
in just a few steps.
Let's go through
the basics, and I'll
point out some options for
additional configuration
along the way.
We'll start by navigating to
Cloud SQL in the GCP console
and clicking Create Instance.
And then next, choose a second
generation MySQL database
engine.
Second generation instances
provide better performance
and improve management
tools, like automatic storage
increase.
I'll name the instance
and then set the password
for our default account.
This instance will
be created in the US,
and we'll leave
the zone set to Any
so Cloud SQL can choose for us.
Let's take a look at
configuration options.
You can specify MySQL
version, instant size,
high availability, and more.
For this demo, I'll
choose a four core,
high-memory instance.
Maximizing memory is a
good choice for MySQL
because it can take
advantage of the extra memory
for performance.
That said, don't worry too
much about initial sizing.
You can scale the
instance up or down later.
Let's increase the storage
capacity to 200 gigabytes,
because increasing disk capacity
also increases performance.
Check out the performance
calculator below.
As I add capacity,
my disk performance
increases, which will
allow my database
to process more
operations per second.
And I'll enable
Automatic Storage
Increase so that I
don't accidentally
run out of disk space.
Lastly, let's ensure that the
database will automatically
provide isolation from failures.
We can do that by enabling
the high availability
configuration, which, for
MySQL, adds a failover
replica in another zone.
Now that we're happy with the
configuration of our instance,
let's kick off the creation.
It may take a few minutes
for your instance to create.
This is a great time to
grab a quick cup of coffee.
You can also check the
status of your instance
by navigating to
your Instance List.
Once you see a green check
mark, your instance is ready.
Looks like our instance
has finished creating.
Let's open the Details
page to continue.
There are many ways to
connect to this instance.
Within GCP, for example, we
could use App Engine, Compute
Engine, or Container Engine.
But we could also connect
from just about anywhere
by authorizing IP addresses
or using the Cloud SQL proxy.
For this demo, I'll connect
using the Google Cloud Shell.
Cloud Shell provides
command line access
to all of your Cloud resources,
such as Cloud SQL instances
directly from the browser.
To open the Cloud Shell, click
Connect Using Cloud Shell.
As you can see, the
relevant Gcloud command
to connect to your
Cloud SQL instance
has been pre-typed for us.
So all we have to
do is press Enter.
And then, enter our root
password from before.
And now, we're connected.
So let's create and
insert some data.
To begin, I'll
create a database.
Next, I'll insert some data.
Finally, I'll make sure the
data is now in our database.
And it is.
Great.
So to recap, in the
last few minutes,
we just created a
Cloud SQL instance
with high performance
and high availability,
and connected to it
with Cloud Shell.
Now that you've seen how to
get started, give it a try.
You can learn more about Google
Cloud SQL in our free trial
program here.
Thank you for watching.